pour faire basculer une ville au niveau
de zone rouge écarlate ou seuil d'alerté
maximale il faut remplir trois critères
or deux sont déjà atteints d'abord le
taux d'incidence de la maladie il doit
être supérieur à 250 cas positifs pour
100000 habitants sur les sept derniers
jours or depuis le 20 septembre cet
indicateur sanitaire est dépassé ce
vendredi il était de 264 selon l'agencé
régionale de santé soit plus de cinq
mille six cent soixante dix cas recensés
dans la capitale française cette semaine
le deuxième facteur est le taux
d'incidence pour les personnes de plus
de 60 ans il doit être supérieur à 100
cas pour 100000 habitants
d'après france info il aurait lui aussi
était dépassée depuis le 20 septembre
cette si longue épidémie peut créer de
l'épuisement ou de la colère mais je ne
vois aucune raison au déni les chiffres
sont là il pèse lourd
les dires par exemple la pression sur
l'hôpital ce n'est pas chercher à
culpabiliser qui que ce soit c'est
responsabiliser chacun et si le besoin
de responsabiliser les uns et les autres
devient primordial c'est parce que le
troisième critère d' alerte maximale
devrait bientôt être atteint dans la
ville lumière un taux de 30 %
d'occupation des lits de réanimation par
des patients atteints du colis 19 selon
les chiffres de la rs ce vendredi ce
taux d'occupation en ile de france s'est
élevé à 34 8% en service de réanimation
nous sommes un peu au dessous des 30% à
paris mais à peine et on sait qu'à 30%
cela veut dire que nous nous retrouvons
dans une situation où il faut choisir
qui on va pouvoir mettre en réanimation
ce dimanche à la proche du seuil maximal
le ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
a invité les cafetiers parisien
renforcer les mesures sanitaires
s'il souhaitait rester ouverts le
gouvernement va dans les prochains jours
examiner les propositions qui lui sont
faites c'est normal par les
représentants du secteur de la
restauration et étudier des règles
éventuels qui pourraient permettre aux
restaurants y compris en zone d' alerte
maximale de rester en tout ou partie
ouvert mais avec des règles sanitaires
renforcés pour permettre de limiter au
maximum les risques de contamination
deux semaines le ministre de la santé et
le premier ministre se sont entretenus
avec les maires des grandes villes paris
lille toulouse un entretien qu'il
n'avait pas eu avec les élus marseillais
avant la fermeture des bars et
restaurants et qui avait provoqué la
colère des patrons d'établissements